three
two
one drop the beat
if i could describe the title experience
in one word exhilarating innovating
curiosity contagious oh my gosh um
worthwhile inspiring eye opening oh
that's two words technically but one
word if you put a hyphen eye opening
hello
this is the very first time that we have
done an event like this every speaker
you'll see today is a member of a ted-ed
club like many of you it's so cool
coming here and meeting people from all
around the world it's just a very like
fun work environment and everyone's
willing to talk to you and work with you
and just show you what they've been
doing so that's like educational
experience but at the same time a very
fun experience
and i think that's a really really
special thing to kind of meet people who
who've had the same experience as me and
we can kind of talk it out and perform
this community and like a family think
about what motivated you all to start
clubs in your schools it's spectacular
it's awesome it's all student based
which makes us feel like we belong in
society while still standing out
you know it's great i don't want to miss
a second of it it's so much fun it's so
much fun i've met people from like gym
who's like so small to like people who
are already in college and we're having
such a good time all of us together
dream team
what a dream team i've made friends
already and i've been here for like four
hours or something
i feel like i've really made lifelong
friends definitely an opportunity that i
was glad that i took it if you could
improve anything about your school what
would it be i think that this experience
to me
is helping me grow as a person because
it's exposing me to many different
things that i didn't know about before
my mind just went
right when i saw it i was like there's
something for me to start thank you
honestly it's just so rewarding to see
like my idea come to life and see other
people um appreciate it and feel sort of
a connection to it it means a lot all
languages are created and molded by the
culture of their speakers the languages
we speak not only help us express our
thoughts but actually shape the very
thoughts we wish to express
people have asked me like so you do this
ted talk now what do you do once you're
done with this
and so like i really want to go
somewhere with this i don't want to just
give the talk and be done i want to like
make a difference
one of the best and most effective ways
you can help special education
departments is by creating or joining a
peer offer program
it makes me feel fulfilled to see my
fellow students get excited about their
education and about their ideas that
they want to share with the world
it's wonderful because it like gives
hope to me and to my peers that we will
be good leaders in the future you know
like we actually will be able to like
handle stuff when we're older and take
care of the planet it's a beautiful
thing i'm very grateful for ted and for
my club for making me a better person
i think it's important that every
student tries to experience this at
least once
just come enjoy and be a part of it like
it is one experience that will probably
get you to new york
[Music]